I heard the Nigerian president say that
there are no gays in Nigeria and I was I
was practically just angry and I find it
quite light rages because I thought but
this is not true I decided to say you
know I'm here you know this is me and I
would not be removed from the history of
of this country basically I mean that
was why I came out on national
television and the reaction was
immediate so I moved from becoming this
loved child of the country to becoming
the most hated person my sexuality is
just a small percentage of who I am it's
on my totality in a country like this
out there you come out and see you again
[Music]
was something in our country because I'm
in the sauna on Africa these laws were
often put in close by my own country
[Music]
Nigeria Africa's most wealthy and
populous nation
[Music]
but it's also one of the most dangerous
places in the world for lesbian gay
bisexual and trans people an
increasingly hostile tone from the
authorities and the enforcement of
recent anti-gay laws has forced the
already discreet queer community into
hiding
one of Nigeria's most senior police
officers even uses her Instagram account
to warn gay people that they should
leave the country or face prosecution
being a gay person in Nigeria is
literally just be like in the jungle if
you're not afraid of being arrested by
the police you are in constant awareness
of your neighbors ganging up against you
and beating you up or being blackmailed
it's a very dangerous life experience to
actually go through on a daily basis BC
Eleni had become a darling of the nation
with the starring role in Nigeria's
favorite TV soap opera but when rumors
circulated about his sexuality in 2004
he risked everything and spoke out I
called up the producer of the most
watched talk show in Nigeria called
nude on which for me
[Music]
and I said I want to come out as gay
yeah on their show and they were quite
shocked it initially was a little bit
like it's not a little bit crazy to them
and they were quite frightened as much
as I was saying about wanting to talk
about being gay in a country like
Nigeria who don't believe that anybody
is gay by Nature I'm not gonna be forced
into marrying a woman because the cycle
wants me to the reaction was inspired I
lost my role on the set I was never
invited back to to play the role I was
playing nobody was going to give me a
job and sometimes I walk down the street
people say things people shot at me and
was quite frightening and terrifying in
the country like these out there you
come out and see you again
a month after that time the group of men
broke into my home and and they knocked
on the door and when I opened the door I
I had a slap across my face I just I
just went blind completely and I was
tired my boyfriend was tied up and they
were beating us you know after the
attack I left like you 24 hours later I
had no plan I had no plan whatsoever I
had no I arranged married there was
there was nothing planned
I just had to leave the country I saw a
future that was bright the future died
was very promising and suddenly because
of my sexuality because I came out I
everything came crashing
[Music]
most Nigerians believe that it's uh naff
ricchan to be gay and over half believe
that homosexuality is a Western
phenomenon another study shows that
almost all Nigerians believe people
can't be born gay the country's two
prominent faiths are the main proponents
of this view in the south is the world's
second largest Anglican community
despite his own British roots the Church
of Nigeria sees no irony condemning
homosexuality as a supposedly Western
phenomenon unlike in the more liberal
Western Anglican community African
church leaders have fiercely resisted
gay bishops and same-sex marriage
Nigeria's former president of asan Joe
described their position as a principled
stand against homosexuality that was
unbiblical unnatural and definitely an
African in Nigeria's predominantly
Muslim North some states are under ultra
conservative Sharia law death by stoning
is the prescribed punishment for
homosexuality in this religious
jurisdiction the two men seen here in
green were among a group who were
arrested and tried for being gay in an
Islamic sharia court in bouchy state at
least one man was punished with 20
lashes in front of a packed court house
the most recent political crackdown on
homosexuality in Nigeria began in 2014
with a general election on the horizon
President Goodluck Jonathan passed the
same sex marriage prohibition act this
law isn't really about same-sex marriage
homosexuality is already punishable by
14 years in prison or by death
in reality this trakone Ian law is
designed to restrict the daily lives of
LGBT people now anyone who supports LGBT
clubs organizations or charities faces
10 years in prison
displaying same-sex affection in public
years attending a gay marriage 10 years
in prison he did the right thing because
that's gays uncalled for
I mean this enough you're on Africa we
don't was something in our country the
organization Human Rights Watch says
that the same sex marriage prohibition
act officially authorizes abuses against
LGBT people vigilantes have used the law
as cover to attack people and police
have even raided HIV awareness meetings
claiming that the participants had been
promoting homosexuality the
international community was outraged by
the law and Nigeria's anti-gay crackdown
was challenged when current President
Muhammadu Buhari met Barack Obama at the
White House in 2015 but according to the
Horace spokesperson the Nigerian
president told American officials that
gay sex is abhorrent to our culture
when you go back in time when you look
at the histories of the different ethnic
groups that come together to make
Nigeria west as you find that they've
always been people who will define today
as being LGBTQ essentially existent in
our respective um communities and so if
anything we should be pushing for with a
narrative that it's very Nigerian it's
okay
to be to be a member of LGBT community
because that in itself is what makes
Nigeria what it is that diversity this
map shows the countries in Africa where
homosexuality is still a crime in June
2019 in many cases it's persisting
colonial-era laws that legislate against
same-sex relationships I am all too
aware that these laws were often put in
place by my own country they were wrong
then and they are wrong now former
British colonies have a particularly
poor record for human rights violations
against LGBT people these two men from
Malawi were sentenced to 14 years in
prison in 2010 for publicly declaring
that they wanted to marry elsewhere in
Africa there are also signs of
progression in January 2019 Angola
decriminalized homosexuality as it
adopted its first penal code since it
gained independence from Portugal in
1975 it removed the antiquated anti-gay
laws in that process
Mozambique did the same in 2015
[Music]
South Africa was one of the first
countries in the world to introduce LGBT
rights into its constitution in the 90s
as it prohibited discrimination on the
grounds of race gender or sexuality it's
the only African country to recognize
same-sex marriage but violent attacks
and in particular corrective rape still
happened despite positive legal changes
these countries are still dangerous
places for LGBT plus people in Eastern
Africa Kenya has become the focal point
in the region in the fight for
decriminalization where people are not
on some agenda trying to make the rest
of the world queer so that we can all be
like in some queer cult it's just about
people allowing people to be themselves
and you know allowing the Constitution
allows for all human beings to be
treated equally in our country but then
the law says otherwise Kaz Lucas hosts a
popular podcast in Kenya called the
spread which discusses sex and sexuality
I found my kinky queer sex positive
community cast as Kenyans are becoming
more accepting of queer people every
time there is a queer party in Kenya
there's always a lot of Eastern Africans
who are in attendance and people who
come here because they feel safer
Uganda also has similar harsh laws on
her on homosexuality so I feel like even
though the laws here are not favoring
LGBT people it's definitely a safer
environment the idea that homosexuality
is unnatural
has severe consequences it's used to
justify human rights abuses enforce
extreme laws extort blackmail deny
proper health care and ultimately it
destroys countless lives across the
continent queer Africans face an uphill
struggle for acceptance
it also has to be said that we are
making progress
the progress we're making might not be
coming quickly enough but I do believe
that change is this is coming in it's
it's definitely happening we have
historical evidence of LGBT history
across the country maybe we don't use
the word lesbian or gay for that because
this was at Western words but to deny
the fact that there are there's an
absence of sin gender loving across the
continent for me was was not just
offensive but I thought it was just
quite stupid in a way and I decided to
say you know I'm here I'm gay and I
would not be removed from the history of
of this country basically
you